we've discussed my
uh piano tuner in previous episodes
no no that was offline conversation you
told me the story but i should tell you
this you should
you should re-tell the story there it
was in darkest manhattan
yeah with the world's shittiest uh it
wasn't even an upright it was a spin-it
piano
a friend had given it to me the piano
fell out of tune
and i would have to tune it and
the only tuner i knew was this russian
guy and i hated dealing with him
there's something about his attitude
just really rubbed me the wrong way
so anyway my wife says tune that thing
so we get the
piano tuner to come and he's tuning this
and he's like are you sure are you sure
you want to tune this
this piece of [ __ ] you know okay fine so
he's like okay it's your money
the phone rings and i have the the phone
ringer set
on a landline to paganini caprice 24.
and immediately as the phone rings he
figures out
what key the phone ringer is and which
is not the key that like
liszt composed the variations on on
uh caprice 24. and he starts going into
theme and variations on caprice 24
at some level i've never heard before
just jaw dropping it
and like the phone stops ringing and we
have this awkward silence
i said i didn't know you were such a
great piano player and then he says one
of these things and
in right you know in russian accented
english hurts in a way you can't imagine
no you are the piano player i am merely
the piano tuner
i was just like oh man through the heart
you